Did you have a position
on carbon credits coming into today?
Tamara Toles O'Laughlin:
Yeah. No, the position is no.
John Kilani: There must be something
important in carbon markets,
otherwise, people would
have given up long ago.
Nat Keohane: So I came in today thinking,
as a tool, carbon markets,
carbon credits can be really valuable
in creating the kind of economic
incentives we need.
Julio Friedmann: Today,
the carbon markets have no supply,
no demand, no transparency, no regulation.
Other than that, they're perfect.
Donnel Baird: You buy
a carbon offset from a forest
but now the forest has burned down
or they were going to chop the tree down
but they didn't, and then they did.
Nili Gilbert: We know that we need
carbon removals to scale dramatically.
Al Gore: Different points of view
can add to the collective wisdom.
Inés Yábar: We'll work better
if we work together.
How do we generate those connections
that together move us forward?
James Dyke: The concern
that I’ve got about net zero,
you're probably going to
disagree about this,
it might be taking away some
of the sense of urgency.
JF: We can be optimistic
or we can be pessimistic.
But the work looks the same.
Is there anything that struck you
about carbon credits
or carbon markets
that you want to talk about?
AG: Well, I'll wait
until the session is over
to give us some considered
opinions on that.
[TED Countdown Dilemma Series]
[Is there a role for carbon credits
in the transition to a fair,]
[net zero future?]
Lindsay Levin: Throughout the world,
we find ourselves faced
with self-inflicted
and interconnected problems
that challenge our social fabric,
our economic security,
and the very ability
of the Earth to sustain us.
We're certainly not short on ideas
to address these problems.
But we often get caught up
in arguments against one another
vying for supremacy instead of deciding
on a course of action.
So how can we move forward?
It begins by acknowledging the difference
between choices and dilemmas.
Some decisions come down to choice.
You weigh the alternatives,
decide and move on.
But often, complex situations need
both/and thinking instead of either/or.
They require us to hold
competing values together
rather than make straightforward choices.
We call these dilemmas.
I'm Lindsay Levin, co-founder
of TED Countdown.
And this is why we launched
our Dilemma Series.
To look at some of the thorniest issues
in the climate space
and see how, through deep listening
and collaboration,
we find pathways forward.
In our first Dilemma event,
we tackled the question
Is there a role for carbon credits
in accelerating the transition
to a fair net-zero world?
David Biello: First, let's start
with some definitions.
A carbon credit is a tradable permit
that usually represents one ton of carbon,
either not emitted or removed
from the atmosphere.
Carbon offsetting is the practice
of buying carbon credits
to compensate for carbon emissions
generated elsewhere.
Carbon markets are where carbon credits
are bought, sold and priced.
Net zero refers to a theoretical state
in which overall human-produced
carbon emissions are equivalent to zero
because any ongoing emissions
have been compensated
or offset by removals.
LL: We're going to take you on a journey.
We'll explore why so many people
have lost faith in how carbon markets
and net-zero targets operate in practice.
We'll hear from people working
in frontline communities
to protect and restore nature
and safeguard livelihoods.
And to close, we'll talk about solutions.
We hope this film will speak to those
working in sustainability and beyond.
Whether you're directly able
to influence the supply
or demand side of carbon markets,
or you're just interested
in how we solve the climate crisis,
these issues affect us all.
Let's start by hearing about some
of the promises and pitfalls
in a conversation
between TED's David Biello
and Gilles Dufrasne
of Carbon Market Watch.
DB: Now, carbon credits
are being used as a big tool
to neutralize otherwise growing emissions.
Are they working?
Gilles Dufrasne: So my short answer
to this would be that they're not.
First, because there is a major concern
around the actual quality
of those credits.
They're each supposed to represent
a full ton of CO2
that's been reduced or removed
and permanently stored.
But in reality,
many of those credits actually
don't represent that full ton of CO2.
In addition to that,
many credits are used
in inappropriate ways by companies.
For example, a company that would
make a net-zero claim,
a carbon neutrality claim
for a specific product,
but with these claims actually
only covering 10 or 20 or 50 percent
of the total emissions
of that company or of the good.
And this ultimately is misleading.
It's misleading to the public,
it's misleading to regulators,
it's misleading to business partners.
It gives the impression
that these companies,
this product doesn't have
a net-negative impact on the climate,
when in reality it certainly does.
DB: So what does it mean
when a company says
it has neutralized the emissions
from its products or activities?
GD: Well, in most cases it means
the company has purchased
a certain number of carbon credits,
but there is a lot of unclarity
around the actual quality
of those credits,
what do they represent
as well as the share of total emissions
that's really being covered,
that's really being compensated
through the purchase of these credits.
And this issue of clarity,
of transparency.
And so I think that's really something
that we need to seriously
address right now
in the current context of a booming market
where there is a lot of interest,
a lot of investment
in growing it quantitatively.
If we don't address the quality
dimension of it,
we're going to grow a system
in which there's not going to be any trust
or that trust is progressively
going to erode
and ultimately that will destroy
the value of the system itself.
DB: Sounds like something
called greenwashing.
Can you give us some particularly
egregious examples
of that kind of activity?
GD: Yeah, I think, you know,
carbon-neutral fossil fuels
is an obvious one ...
(Laughter and applause)
... that many of you will certainly
have had heard of.
I mean, to me, it's just an oxymoron,
it makes no sense.
It is flawed conceptually and practically.
At a conceptual level,
it gives the impression that we can
continue to burn fossil fuels
in the way we’ve been
doing it for decades --
exactly what has landed us
in the crisis we are in today --
and that somehow, magically we can do this
without having a net impact
on climate.
And that is fundamentally
misleading, and it’s damaging.
It is harmful to our
collective willingness
to adopt the behavioral changes
and the costly investments
that we need to adopt
in order to transition to a safer planet.
LL: While we can agree
that cutting greenhouse gas emissions
as soon as possible is our ultimate goal,
the idea of net zero has inspired
some pretty vigorous debate.
Here's Professor James Dyke
of the University of Exeter
with his concerns.
JD: Within just a few years,
net zero has become the anchor concept
for the world's plans to avoid disaster.
It sounds simple enough.
Its central premise
is that the risks of climate change
is that there is too much carbon dioxide
in the Earth’s atmosphere.
So it follows, we must stop emitting more
and even remove some of it.
Hopefully by the middle of this century,
any residual emissions
will be balanced by technologies
that remove carbon from the atmosphere.
But by introducing carbon
removals into climate policies,
we have set a trap
because it is incredibly seductive
to rely on carbon removals in the future
instead of rapid decarbonization now.
It gives the impression we are acting,
so businesses don't need
to change their models
and governments don't need
to propose bold action.
What this means is that it is now
almost inevitable
that we will be entering a warmer
and more dangerous world.
How did this happen?
How did the idea of net zero
become so compromised, so corrupted?
A key moment for the development
of net zero was the 2015 Paris Agreement.
The overall objective
of this landmark climate treaty
was that global warming should be limited
to no more than 1.5 degrees Celsius
to reduce the risks
of devastating impacts.
Many scientists, including myself,
were very skeptical
that this was possible,
given the absence of radical proposals.
But there was also
a deep sense of responsibility
to try to make the Paris Agreement work.
They soon discovered
it was impossible to get their models
to decarbonize as fast as 1.5 required
if one assumed continuous
economic growth.
The only way to make the models work
was by introducing carbon removal.
More recently, attention has turned
to DAC: direct air capture.
This would strip out carbon dioxide
molecules directly from the air
and then pump them
to underground storage sites.
The technology is interesting,
but attempts to scale up DAC
face two fundamental challenges.
First, the process is extremely
energy intensive,
requiring significant amounts
of electricity
and sometimes natural gas to run.
Second, safely storing carbon dioxide
is not a trivial enterprise.
It's likely to be the case
that every carbon storage site
will need to be carefully tailored
to the specific geological circumstances
at the injection sites.
Now such concerns with carbon removal
are sometimes brushed away
with the sheer enthusiasm
that surrounds these technologies.
The assumption appears to be
that large-scale carbon removal will work
because it has to work.
Even if we assume these technologies
do emerge at scale,
it's likely they will be
very expensive to run.
Some studies estimate
many trillions of US dollars
to no evident economic benefit,
since it's about clearing up carbon
pollution and hiding it underground.
The time has come for us to voice
our fears about net zero policies,
and that begins by leveling
with the public
about the Paris Agreement.
At the moment, we are desperately
trying to manage the narrative
and adjusting models
in order to avoid acknowledging
that the Paris Agreement is failing.
A 2021 survey conducted
by the science journal Nature
found that a majority of IPCC
climate scientists who responded
thought we were heading
towards a catastrophic
three degrees Celsius of warming.
Only four percent thought limiting
to 1.5 was likely.
We can avoid climate catastrophe,
but I fear we won't
if we don't confront
our wishful thinking around net zero.
DB: As you can see,
carbon markets are not uniformly
delivering what they promise,
and many believe they may actually
be making things worse.
However, they are potentially
a mechanism to provide investment
in vital natural solutions
and if done differently,
could bring significant money to people
and places that need it.
Here is Kavita Prakash-Mani
of Mandai Nature
to talk about ways to ensure
that local communities
benefit from this growing industry.
Kavita Prakash-Mani: Let me start
by saying that a ton of carbon
is not just a ton of carbon.
It embodies in it natural protection,
community interests and benefits,
as well as helping save us
from disastrous climate change.
We have a lot of nature-based conservation
organizations protecting
and restoring our ecosystems,
and they are all wondering
how they can be part
of this carbon market.
Their ability to monetize carbon
that they sequester
will be crucial for their
long-term survival
and the impact that we all want.
After all, nature and climate
are two sides of the same coin.
However, to get to those opportunities,
we need to address some really
systemic challenges.
Take, for example, the technical aspects
that we have on any carbon credit:
additionality, permanence,
no leakage, baselining,
all very difficult concepts
for these small organizations.
Add to that measurement and verification.
How do we get pre-feasibility studies,
feasibility studies, project development?
How do these small organizations
take on these high costs
when the price of carbon is very low
to deliver these documentation?
But that's not the problem
with the larger players.
And there's a systemic imbalance of power.
Larger NGOs, companies,
project developers
all have access to international markets
and institutional finance.
The smaller organizations
see the opportunity
but just do not have
the means to tap into it.
We should also look
one level higher, at governments.
Take, for instance, Indonesia,
a country with the highest potential
of carbon mitigation
from nature-based solutions.
It's the third-largest tropical forest.
It has a coastline with mangroves,
and it has 15 to 30 million
hectares of peatland.
But the government has restricted
any new projects from being developed
or carbon credits from being sold
to the international market.
This has merit because, after all,
developing countries also need to meet
their nationally determined contributions,
and they do not have to sell cheap credits
to developed countries
that have already destroyed
part of their environment
or companies that are not decarbonizing.
However, it does restrict international
finance from going into conservation
and into communities.
Some countries are trying
to get the market to work.
In Asia, that's Vietnam and Cambodia.
But we still do not have the right market
mechanisms to ensure that it's equitable,
safe and the impact that we want.
DB: As Kavita said, a ton of carbon
is not just a ton of carbon.
To build on that,
here's Susan Chomba of the World
Resources Institute Africa,
to talk in more detail
about all the things we miss
when we think too narrowly
about carbon benefits
and nothing else.
Susan Chomba: So I'm going to talk to you
about all the elements
about carbon markets
that have got nothing to do with carbon.
Our forests, peatlands and oceans
are more than the carbon that they store.
They're the foundation of livelihoods
of billions of people
who depend on them
directly and indirectly.
They provide the hydrological functions
that ensure we have rivers, we have lakes
and that we can grow food successfully.
They are home to biodiversity.
They are also home to indigenous people
who protect them
with their blood, sweat and tears.
So when we lose these ecosystems,
the livelihoods of local communities
and Indigenous people
are adversely affected.
When you look at the way
we designed the carbon markets,
we designed them with various assumptions.
First of all,
carbon markets perpetuate the notion
that our forests and peatlands
are all about carbon.
They overlook the ecosystem services
that these ecosystems provide,
such as clean water,
healthy and nutritious food,
biodiversity and its related services
such as pollination, pest control
and even nitrogen fixation.
Companies are prepared to pay for carbon
because it helps them to tick
either their compliance box
or the public relation boxes.
But rarely do we couple that
with the other ecosystem services
that these natural
ecosystems are providing.
Carbon markets perpetuate the notion
that we can continue with our
fossil fuel-driven lifestyles
and offset our externalities,
and perhaps even our guilt,
on the poor local communities
that are located in the Global South.
In fact, nowadays,
if a lot of projects provide
a lot of ecosystem services
but are not solid on the carbon side,
they are often dismissed as poorly
designed or poorly governed.
Carbon markets are based on complicated
and costly reporting
and verification systems.
And these end up taking up
most of the revenue
that is then coming from carbon.
And local communities get
the leftovers if they are lucky.
The value and the price of carbon,
compared to alternative
land uses such as mining,
fossil fuel extraction,
has been far too low for far too long.
And so what we are witnessing
is governments in the Global South
continue to issue permits for mining,
for oil exploration,
in some of the most critical
ecosystems: peatlands, forests.
I work a lot in the Congo Basin.
I see it every day.
LL: So we've heard what isn't working
and what existing carbon markets
often miss on the ground.
Now let's dive into different
ways of thinking
that could reshape the system
and actually generate
the positive outcomes we want.
Here's Gabrielle Walker
of Rethinking Removals.
Gabrielle Walker: I think the carbon
market is immensely powerful
and immensely valuable,
and I do think we can use it
as a powerful tool
for helping to solve the climate crisis.
But I've also started to think
that we've been thinking
about it the wrong way.
There are three really big
and important climate outcomes
that the carbon market could help with.
So there’s reducing fossil emissions
as fast as possible;
there’s protecting natural carbon sinks;
and there's removing CO2
from the atmosphere.
Reduction, protection and removal.
And I found that in lots
of people's minds,
those three get kind of smooshed together
in one generic kind of, offset,
but it's worth separating them out
because those outcomes need
different kinds of incentives.
I'll show you what I mean.
If you start with the first one,
reducing fossil emissions
as fast as possible.
That's reduction credits.
Now, one problem with those
is that they don't actually
neutralize emissions.
So if I put a ton of CO2 in the air,
and I pay you not to put
your ton of CO2 in the air,
my ton is still there.
It doesn't get you to zero,
it doesn't neutralize.
And this is the realm of quite
a lot of traditional offsets.
Another issue with them,
is they tend to be very cheap,
less than 20 dollars a ton.
So it can get immensely tempting
just to buy loads of credits
and not do the hard work
of reducing your own emissions.
And that is not where
we should be putting the money.
But where reduction credits can help us
is in creating clean infrastructure
in places where it wouldn't
have happened otherwise.
So if you think about it that way,
that's the outcome
you're trying to get to,
then the incentives to build
around reduction credits,
the highest-rated reduction credits,
will be the ones that drive money
towards building clean infrastructure
in the Global South.
And the cheapest coal-fired
power plant to shut down
will be the one in the Global South
that was never built in the first place.
OK, so that's the first one.
Second one, protecting
natural carbon sinks.
Now, these already exist
in the carbon market,
like the reduction credits.
And like reduction credits,
they don't neutralize emissions.
I put a ton of CO2 in the air,
you stop a ton coming out from a sink,
my ton's still in the air.
They also tend to get smooshed together.
There isn’t a separate category
called protection credits -- yet.
And I think it's worth
separating them out
because it's hugely important
to drive money
towards protecting those sinks,
rain forests, peatlands.
So then what incentives
do you build around?
What are the highest-rated
protection credits?
They'd be the ones maybe
with the biggest carbon stores,
maybe the ones that are most vulnerable,
maybe the ones that protect
the most biodiversity,
maybe the ones that drive the money
towards the communities
that are actually there husbanding
and protecting those stores.
OK, third category,
we’ve heard a lot about this,
third category: removal credits.
That's taking a ton of CO2
out of the atmosphere and keeping it out.
So unlike the other two
categories of credit,
removals credits
really do neutralize emissions.
If I put a ton of CO2 in the air,
I pay you to remove a ton,
you get to zero
because what goes up does come down.
Those are the only category of credits
that can be used to claim net zero.
None of the others can do it.
They do already exist
in the carbon market,
really tiny percentage of the total.
And we're going to need
an awful lot more of them.
So at the moment,
every year we're removing durably
maybe 100,000 tons of CO2.
And according to the IPCC,
carbon removals are now unavoidable
to get to net zero by 2050.
And by 2050,
we're going to have to be removing
billions of tons.
So to get from a 100,000 tons
to billions of tons,
we're going to have to start really small
in this almost nonexistent industry
and scale it up
to the gigaton scale, affordably,
without causing other
undesirable side effects
and making sure
that these removals are real.
And we've got to get
the cost down very quickly
the way that we did for solar and wind.
So that's the objective,
that's the outcome
that we're trying to achieve.
DB: So that's a way to reorganize
our overall thinking
around carbon credits.
But how should companies
reshape their thinking?
Here is Derik Broekhoff of the Stockholm
Environment Institute.
Derik Broekhoff: Net zero has become
the dominant paradigm
for climate ambition.
Many countries have announced
net-zero targets,
and so many companies are doing the same.
Today, I want to challenge the idea
that companies should emphasize
achieving net zero for themselves
rather than focus on how best
to contribute to global net zero.
I like the way Carbone 4 frames it:
"'A company is not carbon neutral.
It contributes to neutrality."
Let me explain why I believe
it's essential to make this distinction.
Current net-zero frameworks
presume that companies should imitate,
at a corporate level,
what must happen globally.
That is, reduce their own emissions
as far as possible
and balance out the emissions that remain
with carbon dioxide removals.
Yet this notion is already leading
to a perverse effect
on how companies spend
their mitigation dollars.
According to at least one study,
just a handful of companies
have already pledged more removals
than the entire world could provide.
At a global level,
removing carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere
will be essential
for limiting global warming.
As the IPCC, for example,
has made abundantly clear.
But having corporate actors
purchase removals in bulk
to achieve their own
mini versions of net zero
misses the forest for the trees.
The world desperately needs
to reduce emissions.
To move the world towards net zero,
companies would do better in the near term
to both reduce their own emissions
and help others do the same.
First, focus on the big picture.
The idea of achieving net zero
at a corporate level is self-centered.
We need to change the narrative from:
“We’re no longer part of the problem
if we’ve neutralized our emissions,”
to “We are part of a global solution
to climate change.”
This means not just imitating
what needs to happen globally,
but instead taking actions
that beneficially advance
a global net-zero outcome,
including by prioritizing
emission reductions over removals
in the near term.
Second, put equity front and center.
From a scientific perspective,
there's no reason why the correct
level of emissions
for any given actor should be net zero.
What is fair and feasible
could be net positive,
zero or negative emissions.
Companies should focus on making
equitable contributions to global goals,
including through near-term support
for emission reductions
outside their value chains.
Third, connect with larger policy efforts.
No company acting on its own
can solve the climate crisis.
We urgently need to focus attention
on collective action.
Companies that are truly
committed to net zero
need to support climate policies
at all levels of government
and internationally
that advance an equitable, comprehensive
and coordinated global transition.
LL: We know many people
think carbon credits
and the idea of net zero
are deeply flawed.
But do they have to be?
In our next talk,
Annette Nazareth of the Integrity Council
for Voluntary Carbon Markets
lays out a set of required core principles
to build a market that delivers
robust, quantifiable
and climate-positive outcomes.
Annette Nazareth: Our starting point
for the voluntary carbon market
is that it exists to accelerate
a just transition to 1.5 degrees.
It is an important complementary tool
to mobilize billions of dollars
that wouldn't otherwise be available
into climate mitigation
that wouldn't otherwise happen.
But it will only deliver on that promise
if it is rooted in high integrity.
An important thing to know
about the voluntary carbon markets
is that it is, as its name
suggests, voluntary.
It's driven by private sector actors,
and it's not regulated by governments
or by financial authorities.
But unregulated cannot mean
chaotic or opaque.
I spent much of my career
as a markets regulator,
and I know markets.
And I know that there are some who think
that markets are always looking
for some new product to hawk.
And today, that product is carbon.
That's why in designing
an effective market,
we have to start with integrity.
These core carbon principles,
which we call CCPs,
will address the most critical
elements of credit quality.
They include additionality,
permanence, robust quantification,
validation and verification,
no double-counting,
transition to net zero emissions
and sustainable development
impacts and safeguards.
So let me unpack those a bit.
Additionality.
Additionality means
that the emission reduction or emission
wouldn't have happened
without the revenue from carbon credits.
Permanence means that those reductions
and removals will stand the test of time.
And if they don't,
they will be fully compensated.
An example of that
would be a forestry project
that issues carbon credits
that is then destroyed in a wildfire.
Robust quantification means
that the impact of the credits
is accurately measured
and accounted for conservatively
based on solid science.
Validation and verification means
that the numbers
are genuine and meaningful
and are validated and verified
by an accredited body
that has the integrity
to do that job robustly.
No double-counting means
that a carbon credit is registered
and issued only once,
and the emissions reductions and removals
that that credit generates
will only be claimed by one party.
Meanwhile,
our colleagues at the Voluntary Carbon
Markets Integrity Initiative, the VCMI,
are working on similar standards
that will address credible claims
so that we can come
to a common understanding
that carbon credits will only count
if they are used as a complementary tool
within a legitimate net-zero pathway.
If we have integrity
in the supply of credits,
how they are traded and how they are used,
then a powerful price signal will emerge.
LL: The Dilemma Series was born
out of a strong conviction
that when reasonable people disagree,
the way out is not to dismiss
one side over another,
but in fact to hold and value
different points of view
and see what we can generate together.
In dilemma thinking,
this is called the resolution zone,
and reaching it is vital if we are going
to make real progress on climate.
Let's hear again from some leading voices
who we invited to share ideas,
ask questions and engage
in productive debate.
NG: In my inbox, every day,
are the debates in the climate community
about how exactly
we're going to get this done.
And the debates are important
because this is the hardest problem
that we've ever faced.
And so we have to have open ears,
even more open perhaps to our critics
than to the ones who agree with us
because we have so much to figure out at
TTO: I had a good conversation about how,
as much as I would like to pretend
we're going to get there on climate
because of trust and relationships,
we've wasted all the time for that
so we really need
to get there by alignment.
If we can agree to a few things
that lead to not dying
on a fiery gas ball,
I will build my relationships
on the way to that.
NK: We heard in the first sessions
about how to make sure
that the carbon market is working
for people on the ground
and communities on the ground
who didn't do anything
to contribute to climate change
are going to be often the most vulnerable
to bearing the brunt of its impacts.
They're not thinking
about the carbon market,
we heard that from Susan Chomba
from her work in Burundi,
and from Kavita Prakash-Mani from her work
with smallholders in Southeast Asia.
JF: The thing that shifted
my thinking the most
was the way that Annette Nazareth talked
about what is necessary to create
in an integrated
and high-integrity carbon market.
That level of clarity
I found actually shifted my mind
in terms of structuring a market
in a valuable way.
DB: There were a lot of
kind of, overlapping ideas
on how to get to solutions from people
who don't really agree on everything.
JD: All carbon removal proposals
need to be based on robust science,
engineering and economics.
Once we have a credible
total amount of carbon
that can be removed by proposed technology
that includes its capture
and safe storage,
then and only then can it be included
in net-zero policies and models.
GW: So to get from 100,000 tons
to billions of tons,
we're going to have to start really small
in this almost nonexistent industry
and scale it up to the gigaton scale
affordably without causing other
undesirable side effects
of making sure
that these removals are real.
KPM: On the government side, we need
clear guidance and clear regulation.
SC: Good carbon markets must help us
to cut emissions from the source.
We have to decarbonize our supply chains.
We have to decarbonize our economies.
We have to decarbonize our lifestyles.
TTO: I think deep listening really matters
for conversations
like the ones we had today
and the ongoing thorniness
of people who feel threatened
by a planet in decline
trying to make decisions.
JF: The heterodoxy of perspective
and opinion stimulates new ideas.
And if you start the conversations
with respect and with open minds,
you get to new places.
And we had that in our
breakout group, for sure.
JD: But we need a kind of grounded sense
of hope and optimism,
which has got kind of
rough edges and realism.
Tom Rivett-Carnac: I agree.
JD: And we somehow need
to embrace those fears
because often we don't want to, right?
TRC: So I think that a stubborn
and determined optimism
lies on the other side of despair.
I think you have to go through that
and you have to stare into the abyss
and say: “This is possible,
it may even be likely, but you know what?
I'm going to do everything
I can at this moment
to be the change,
to create that difference."
TTO: I've never heard
so many polite people
disagree about things they hate.
I've never met so many people
who hate offsets,
who are still super nice and trying
to figure out what could be useful
about a thing they're not sold on.
DB: It is useful to be reminded to like,
be patient, to listen, to learn,
to be open, to be warm,
to be generous and kind to people
who are on my side that I disagree with.
IY: Sometimes we do need
to take a step back
and not put all that pressure
on our own shoulders
that we're going to find the solution.
But it’s: How do we generate
those connections
that together move us forward?
And maybe one day I will be sadder
and I will be less optimistic,
but someone else will bring
that hope to me.
AG: When we try to reason collectively,
it's really important
and valuable to recognize
that different points of view
can add to the collective wisdom.
One of the most powerful
telescopes in the world
had an innovative design
when it was built,
including the decision to build two
virtually identical telescopes
only 60 meters apart.
If they're looking at a supernova,
100 million light years away,
it turns out that the ability
to view that object
from two different points of view
only 60 meters apart
on a small planet makes all the difference
in the amount of information
that can be collected and processed
and used to enhance our understanding.
And the same thing is true when we try
to reason together in a group.
If there are different points of view,
then the different life experiences
of everyone in the group
can add to the collective wisdom
and make the group far smarter
than the smartest individual
in that group.